لكن هل سيكون التعليق إلى أجل غير مسمى في
هذه المرحلة كافيا،
لا لن يكون كافيا حتى لو
أخرته دون أي تعليق
لأننا في الأساس
شهدنا بالفعل عنصرين أحدهما
تشريع وحشي للغاية يستعبد في الأساس
أه المتصل الذي هو
العقل التشريعي ل
السلطة التنفيذية وتمرير القوانين، لا أريد
حتى الخوض في نوع من القوانين المجنونة تمامًا
التي لا تقبلها أي ديمقراطية رئيس
المحكمة العليا استانسيا، رئيس المحكمة العليا لدينا، الذي
أعلن بالفعل أن هذا
إصلاح آخر في النظام القضائي ولكنه
محاولة لتحطيمه  استقلال
النظام القضائي وإخراج إسرائيل
من أسرة الدول الديمقراطية،
لم نصل إلى هذه المرحلة، ولسنا مستعدين لأن نكون
مثل المجر أو بولندا وسنقاتل
ضدها وسنفوز
بالحرس الوطني، ليست فكرة غبية،
ربما تكون هناك حاجة إليها  ولكن إذا كان الشخص الذي
يريد ذلك هو أحد كبار رجال الشرطة الرسميين
أو السياسيين الذين يعانون من
انعدام الأمن في الخلفية، فلا بأس، لكن
هذا الرجل تم اتهامه 53 مرة
وأدين ثماني مرات،
كانت إحداها تتعلق بالإرهاب وليس العرب
بالفندق داخل  الجالية اليهودية،
هذه خطوة مجنونة من نتنياهو
تظهر إلى أي مدى لا يستطيع إصدار
حكم صادق على ما هو أجنبي هناك